Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass mit seiner Ausgabe 193. Wir wollen auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen gucken in unserem beliebten Format Ligatour, zu dem ich euch sehr herzlich begrüße. Und jetzt geht's los. Es wird mal wieder Zeit hier im Rasenfunk auf die Europäischen Top-Ligen zu gucken. Wir wollen schauen auf die Premier League, auf die Serie A, auf die Liga, auf La Liga. Wie immer habe ich dazu eine Reihe von Gästen, die ich gleich mit dem Plädoyer hier begrüßen werde. Das wird unser Einstieg. Ich begrüße zum einen Alex Truica ist da für La Liga. Was hast du denn uns für Themen mitgebracht?
Hola, buenas. Ja, viele Themen aus Spanien. Denn da wird sehr viel Fußball gespielt. Und zwar nicht nur in La Liga, sondern Copa del Rey, Super Copa, Liga. Da geht es drunter und drüber. Sehr Salami-Spieltag. Da gibt es einiges zu besprechen.
Und würdest du sagen, dass das Bild von Nico Kovac als Trainer gelitten hat jetzt durch diese Entlassung? Es ist ja schon interessant, dass man wieder von Problemen mit einzelnen Spielern hört.
Du meinst ihn im Hinblick vielleicht auf eine baldige Zukunft in Deutschland?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich da jetzt draufkomme.
Borussia Dortmund vielleicht sogar. Dann hat sein Bild ja nicht gelitten. Ja, er hat schon einen guten Ruf in Deutschland. Sobald er in Monaco entlassen wurde, hat man gehört, wo könnte Kovac gut gebaut werden? In einigen namhaften Clubs wird es bald eine freie Stelle geben. Vielleicht wird es Dortmund, vielleicht Borussia Mönchengladbach, vielleicht wird es Hertha. Aber er will sicherlich zu einem ambitionierten Verein, wo er die Mannschaft in die Champions League führen kann. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sein Ruf darunter leiden wird, weil wenn man über Kovac spricht in Deutschland, habe ich das Gefühl, hätte man immer von einem Kovac, der Frankfurt zum Pokalsieg geführt hat und nicht unbedingt der in München gescheitert ist. Ich bin sicher, dass Kovac im Sommer in der Bundesliga zurück ist, und zwar bei einem der zwei Büros hier.
Okay, sehr gut. Alexi lehnt sich gern aus dem Fenster, das mag ich. Dann habe ich jetzt noch eine abschließende Frage, die jeder von euch beantworten darf. Alex, du darfst mal beginnen. Welcher Spieler aus La Liga macht dir denn aktuell am meisten Freude?
Oha, da werde ich jetzt unvorbereitet erwischt. Ich sage, ich beantworte das mal nicht ganz fachgerecht. Ich sage, ich freue mich sehr auf Ferran Torres, den Neuzugang des FC Barcelona. Der hat ja noch nichts geleistet. Der kam ja nämlich noch nicht in La Liga zum Einsatz. Wird aber jetzt zum Einsatz kommen, zum ersten Mal am Wochenende. Darauf freue ich mich.
Warum kann jetzt auf einmal Barca wieder Spieler verpflichten?
Tja, weil man Geld gefunden hat in den Sofa-Ritzen. Schlanke 55 Millionen. Weil sie tatsächlich die Ablöse so mehr stückelen, wie das im Fußball völlig normal ist. Also sprich, sie zahlen diese 55 Millionen nicht auf einmal, sondern auf die, ich meine, sogar 5 Jahre Vertragsdauer.
Na, das kann ja nur gut gehen.
Und die erste Charge wird erst im Sommer fällig. Also sie zahlen im Sommer nur, was sind das, dann 11, 14, 15, irgendwie sowas dann, Millionen. Also es ist nicht so viel, wenn man es über die Laufzeit abstottert. Das ist der eine Grund. Der andere Grund sind natürlich, sie nehmen ja trotzdem Geld ein. Sie haben Champions League gespielt und das Stadion ist wieder voller. Et cetera, et cetera. Also es fließt Geld. Sie konnten die Gehälter ein bisschen zurückschrauben. Der ein oder andere verzichtet auf Geld. Und so konnten sie ein bisschen was einnehmen. Und geben es gerne wieder aus.
Also Ferran Torres ist der Spieler der Wahl von Alex. Christian, welcher Spieler aus der Serie A macht hier gerade so richtig Freude? Also da ich ja davon ausgehe, dass jetzt sehr viele Offensivspieler genannt werden, hier gerade bei solchen Kategorien, gehe ich mal vielleicht ein bisschen in die andere Richtung und nenne Alessandro Bastoni von Inter. Innenverteidiger aus der Dreierkette. Also ich weiß schon, er ist ja Teil des Europameisterschaftskaders, absoluter Stammspieler auch schon unter Konter. Also das ist jetzt keine, wie soll man sagen, große Neuigkeit. Aber ich finde, er entwickelt sich nochmal großartig weiter. Ist auch so ein bisschen symbolisch für die neue spielerische Freiheit, Leichtigkeit, die Simone Insagi bei Inter gebracht hat nach diesem sehr dogmatischen Antonio Conte-Fußball. Da hat man das Gefühl, dass da alles so ein bisschen befreiter aufspielen, auch wirklich auch offensiv andere Abläufe da sind. Und Pastoni ist da weit viel, viel mehr als nur einer aus der Dreierkette. Der hat sich zuletzt immer wieder Tore vorbereitet, selber getroffen gegen Lazio 1, vorbereitet per Flanke. Wo man sich vielleicht fragt, oh, da war er zufälligerweise auf der linken Außenbahn. War aber kein Zufall, weil er sich, weil er Teil dieses Insagesystems ist, dass auch mindestens immer einer aus der Dreierkette sich wirklich weit bis mit nach vorne mit einschaltet, oft auch direkt am Strafraum beteiligt. Und er ist auch auf dem Weg, wirklich so ein richtiger Leader zu werden bei Inter. Er und Barella zusammen sind die zwei jungen Italiener, die da auch für die Zukunft von Inter stehen. Und Inter steht ja auch nicht ganz schlecht da. Deswegen würde ich mal Herrn Bastoni nennen. Sehr gute Wahl. Hendrik, wer aus der Premier League macht dir Spaß?
Um vielleicht mal einen der weniger offensichtlichen Spieler zu nennen, würde ich Jared Bone von West Ham United nennen. West Ham spielt ja wieder mal eine starke Saison, das vierte Moment. Und Jared Bone rechts außen ist da einer der entscheidenden Spieler mit jetzt schon sechs Toren und neun Vorlagen. Also spielt eine ganz starke Saison. Gilt auch so ein bisschen als Außenseiterkandidat für die englische Nationalmannschaft und die WM, gerade da Harry Kane in dieser Saison noch nicht so richtig in Fahrt kommt. Und ist auch ein Spieler, der immer wieder genannt wird, zum Beispiel in Verbindung mit dem FC Liverpool. Genau, also Jared Bone von West Ham ist ein Spieler, den man sich anschauen sollte.
Und jetzt bin ich gespannt, ob Alexi Leo Messi sagt oder jemand anderen. Alexi, wer macht dir in der Liga Freude?
Natürlich könnte ich sagen, Kylian Mbappé, der ein Tor an dem anderen erzählt und der momentan wirklich der wahre Chef geworden ist von PSG, weil Messi ihn immer verletzt oder keine Lust haben. Aber ich bin auch ein bisschen Fan von Außenseitern. Und bei Racing Club de Lens gibt es einen, der nicht mehr lange in der Liga bleiben kann, weil er einfach zu stark ist. Ja, es ist Eko Fofanar und Christian Kendin, denke ich mal, weil er bei Udiné war vor ein paar Jahren. Und während er stark ist, er kann wirklich alles, als 6er, 8er, Bälle zurückerobern, technisch nach vorne, mit Bälle in die Tiefe, zweikampfstark, dynamisch und sehr, sehr konstant vor allem. Er ist auf dem Zettel einiger Vereine. Bernly hat vor ein paar Tagen 17 Millionen Euro angeboten, hat Lons natürlich nur zu einem Lächeln gebracht. Und wenn ihr Lust habt auf die Liga 1 und zumindest einen neuen Spieler entdecken möchtet, dann guckt ihr den mal an, weil er macht einfach Spaß.
Vorfahrener werden wir uns angucken. Ihr vier, ich danke euch sehr herzlich für eure Zeit. Ich mach das jetzt mal im Kollektiv. Danke euch, dass ihr mit dabei wart im Rasenfunk. Wer euch folgen möchte in den diversen sozialen Netzwerken, der findet alle Links in den Show Notes. Danke, dass ihr hier wart. Ja, gerne. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ihr könnt noch mitmachen, das ist mir tatsächlich noch wichtig. Auf dkms.de/rasenfunkkönntihr euch als Spender registrieren lassen. Wir machen da gerade zusammen mit einigen anderen Fußball-Podcasts eine Registrierungsaktion. Und was soll ich sagen? Wir haben plötzlich einen Gegner. Nachdem der Rasenfunk lange die Registrierungsliste angeführt hat, ist jetzt Bundesliga mit dazu gekommen. Also ihr müsst euch bitte registrieren oder jemanden aktivieren, dass er sich registriert, wenn ihr es schon seid. dkms.de/rasenfunkistfür eine gute Sache. Wir helfen damit Menschen, die eine Blutkrebsdiagnose bekommen haben. Und allein während dieser Sendung sind das, mal kurz im Kopf überschlafen, 6 Menschen, die im Durchschnitt gesehen diese Diagnose bekommen haben. Und ihr könnt den Rasenfunk finanziell unterstützen unter rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Auch unsere Gäste bekommen eine Honorar. Danke für eure Unterstützung, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.